[Music]
VI
uh first of all it's really a great
pleasure and honor being here with you I
heard about uh your program and so on
very popular so it's great to be in
Paris one of my very favorite cities in
the world um I'm uh I'm an
economist uh I was born um in Istanbul
in Turkey my family is a Jewish Family
from Iran one as year old will have
Istanbul went back to Teran by the age
of three we moved to Tel Aviv in Israel
and by the age of 4 uh we moved to
Milano in Italy where we settled and I
grew up there I went to school there I
did my university studies first degree
at Boni
University and then in 1983 I came to
the United States for my
PhD uh in
economics at Harvard University then I
was a professor at y University for S
years then by 1995 I moved to New York
University I've been a professor since
then but uh at some point I started also
being involved into Economic Policy I
spent two years in Washington in the
white house and then the US Treasury
Department when Clinton was President
then I went back to Academia but and I
started a few economic
consultancies around 2004 2005 and I
guess that I'm most well known for being
one of the few Economist who predicted
the global financial crisis of 2007
2009 at that point I got this nickname
of Dr Doom is is still sticking uh today
and I've been involved into both working
as a speaker as an academic
as an economic advisor running economic
consultancies writing books my latest
one just published in France Mega
threats 10 dangerous trends that imperil
our future and how to survive them and I
now spend more than half of my time
traveling around the world and make
sensing make sense of this very
complicated and unstable and certain
world I beg your pattern because was uh
we've got some technical problems with
the translation technique but it's my
fault sorry for the the moving hair
pluck every time
[Music]
C
well that's a very good and important
question I think that um there's
something about uh Humanity about trying
to avoid facing
reality uh avoiding uh worrying about
the things can go wrong because if you
worry about them uh you have to prepare
yourself you have to take action those
actions are costly in terms of time
money and effort and people
I live in the hope that something good
is going to happen maybe some Force like
God is going to come and rescue them
from their trouble or that some leader
is going to come and make the right
policy avoid the crisis and so on or
there is some technological Revolution
or some kind of a good luck that's going
to prevent them so we tend to as much as
we can to Kick the Can down the road
sometimes when there's a threat we put
our heads in the sand like ostriches
trying to avoid the problems and
whenever people like me warn about uh
the tail risks uh either they dismiss
you saying you're are Dr M Doom or
you're a Cassandra or when I sound alarm
you know they live like zombies they
want to go back to sleep so they push
this snooze button and then we alarm
again s the botton and then this way you
slip walk into not being aware of what's
going on and eventually you s walk into
disaster
[Music]
um well I would say it depends of course
on the
politicians um some of them are more
aware of this threats uh some of them
ignore them whether they're aware of
them or
not uh politicians in Democratic
countries need to be
reelected and therefore for example
among all these threats that I discuss
in my book each one of them has some
solutions but this solution imply costs
and sacrifices and short run for a
benefit that comes only over the medium
long term and if you do something
unpopular the risk is that you're not
going to get
reelected and I'll give you one example
you know former counselor of Germany
Shredder he was a Social Democrat he did
the reform to make the labor market more
flexible and that was one of the reason
why Germany became competitive but then
he lost elections because those reforms
were highly
unpopular or take another more recent
example right now president of France
macron is proposing a pension reform
that is highly unpopular unpopular among
the left the workers the unions the
Youth Organization unpopular on the
right among lean and other voters and
it's a dilemma because if he passes it
unpopular maybe through a decree or
through an alliance with Republican
forces it could have massive
demonstration it could become even more
unpopular and the chances that uh lean
may get reele may get elected in 2027
rise on the other side if he doesn't do
the reform people are going to say we
elected you on a campaign of proposal
for reform what have you done for all
these years and maybe becomes unpopular
because of that and then maybe whoever
is going to be representative of his
party or moderate forces could still
lose in 2027
um even in non-democracies I think it's
difficult uh people say autocratic
regimes can make tough choices that's
not truly the case because even in
autocratic regimes like China you have
to be sensitive to popular
opinion uh one two you have to make
tough decisions that imply cost in the
short run three sometimes autocrats live
in a bubble like Putin lived in a bubble
with realize the risks CU nobody wanted
to tell him they were scared of him and
I think the shinpin also lives in a
bubble with nobody wants to say the
emperor has no clothes or our policy
doesn't work and therefore in
autocracies you also make uh terrible
decisions you know rightly Winston
Churchill once said that the democracy
is the worst political system apart from
all the Alternatives and it's true I
still believe that with all the
difficulties of liberal democracy it's a
better system of governance than having
an autocratic regimes autocratic regimes
make major mistakes economic social
sometimes they become aggressive and
violent when domestically you have a
problem you find some scapegoat some
external Potential Threat or invented
threat and often dictators end up going
to war Putin did it the Argentine hun
did it and many other examp examples of
that
um it's interesting because I I wrote
this book uh about how the world can
evolve in the next 10 to 20
years and of course some of those
threats are more slow motion some of
them are more
imminent but um even though they look
like more in the future I can give you
many examples of how each one of these
10 threats is materializing today not a
year from now not five years from now
give you 10 example for each one of
these 10 threats so of course in the
short run the risk of inflation the risk
of recession what we call stock flation
the combination of inflation and
recession is a significant material list
for us as Europe advanced economies the
risk of debts becoming unsustainable as
Central Bank increase interest rates is
also a short-term threat but for
example think about the risk of
geopolitical uh tensions the risk of war
between great Powers is reason is not
just anymore a cold war between us and a
number of revisionist Powers would
challenge the economic
social monetary trade political military
order that the US Europe and the West
created after World War II these
revisionist Powers being China Russia
Iran North Korea and even Pakistan that
effectively
highlight but today is not just a cold
war we already have a hot war between uh
Russia and Ukraine this is effectively
already a proxy war between us and
Europe on one side the west and Russia
this war could under some condition
become
unconventional if Putin decides use
tactical nuclear weapons in Ukraine and
it could also involve the uh NATO so
it's a threat that is immediate it's not
10 years from now I was just spending 10
days in Israel before coming to Europe
and uh at this point is clear that Iran
is a threshold nuclear State and Israel
in the next year or so together with the
us will have to make tough decisions on
whether to strike Iran or not and there
are cost and benefits of doing one or
the other plus the Middle East overall
is a powder KAG you have the Sunni Shia
tensions you already have these proxy
wars leading to fail state States in
Lebanon in Syria in Iraq in Libya in
Yemen and things could escalate more and
of course in Asia this cold war between
us and China is becoming colder and the
head of the US Navy a couple of months
ago made a statement in the front page
of the financial times saying that the
chances that China May invade Taiwan are
high
not five or 10 years from now he said at
that time it could happen before
2024 this was in October of last year
well before 2024 means
2023 we are right now
2023 now I'm not claiming that that war
between us and China on the is of Taiwan
is going to occur this year but even
this geopolitical depression and the
risk of a war between great Powers all
of which by the way have a nuclear
weapon or effective like Iran are
getting there it's a risk that is a new
risk that did not
exist I grew up in the 50s 60s and
70s and I never worried about war
between great powers or a nuclear winter
because uh Nixon went to China there was
a Deton between us and the Soviet Union
and the risk of a nuclear war between
these Rivals that had nuclear weapon
became very low not zero but very low
today for the first time in a long time
we have to worry about war between great
powers and a war that from conventional
of course would automatically become
unconventional when you start killing
each other so even things that look like
medium long-term global climate change
pandemics or war between great power or
the impact say of artificial
intelligence robotic and automation
these things are already happening today
even if of course compared to inflation
and stock flation that are more slow
motion train
[Music]
racks for
well different politicians to different
degrees are aware of the
problem uh the problem is that U while
we all worry about the climate change
and is one of the biggest risk because
it could literally destroy the planet in
the next few decades finding solution is
difficult for many and different reasons
there are several of them of why unquote
were're not doing the right thing you
know reason number
one uh in many countries starting with
the United States some part of the
population does not even believe in
human driven climate change so in us
when the Republicans are in power they
don't do anything and sometimes they are
in power and they may come back in power
in
2024 second problem is a
intergenerational conflict you know I'm
64 if I live in another 30 years I'll be
lucky a young man or woman born today
has a life expectancy of at least a 100
years so he or she will have to deal
with the mess Al clim change but young
people don't tend to vote old people do
and even the young people we tend to
Discount the future hoping that maybe
some miracle some technology going to
resolve so how many people are willing
to change their lifestyle today even
young to deal with reducing their own
carbon footprint if we all were vegan
one quarter of all Greenhouse emissions
comes from livestock agriculture I many
of us are willing to insulate fully our
homes putting solar panel using reusable
bags wherever we go how many of us we
all have closets full of clothes
t-shirts shirts pants we know every wear
each one of them causes pollution but we
buy we over consume so there is this
conflict in young and old as well three
globally if a country makes all the work
and effort to reduce their net emission
to zero it's highly costly
but nobody else does they don't get any
benefits the emissions are Global you
pay the cost and coordinating between
200 countries on that is very hard there
a free rider problem what they call it
problem number
four there's a conflict between poor
countries and rich countries us and
Europe are telling China in the Emerging
Market cut your emission to zero over
the next 20 years like we want to do it
but they say you guys created this
problem with 200 years of history of
industrialization 90% of all the
cumulative stock of past emission is you
guys is through that the current new
flow of new emission comes a lot from
China India and other Emerging Markets
they say you created a problem we want
don't want to stay poor we're going to
increase our emission for another 20
years until we are wealthy enough and
then we're going to deal with that
problem unless you give us subsidies
enough to pay the cost today but the
subsidies are estimated in at least a
trillion dollar per year that the rich
will have to transfer to the poor the US
Congress just passed a bill where they
give to Emerging Markets 4 billion it's
just spare change you need a trillion of
course no K is going to do it problem
number five there's a conflict between
in us and China Cold War they don't
agree on pandemics they blame each other
they don't agree on Global Security they
don't agree on free trade they don't
agree on how to deal with economic and
financial crisis and of course they
don't agree on climate change and we
should be doing it and so on and so on
problem number
six um in order to achieve the Paris
Accord targets the average carbon tax
tax should be $200 per ton today the
average carbon tax is $2 per ton Less in
us even more in Europe which politicians
going to increase carbon taxes by a
factor of 100 from two to 200 no one
it's politically impossible if anything
we're doing the contrary now that fuel
prices are high heating costs are high
every politician is cutting fuel taxes
carbon taxes to reduce inflation for the
people but if those taxes are not high
the transition from fossil fuel to
renewable is not going to occur you need
to give the price
incentive finally of the three solutions
for climate change mitigation Net Zero
implies negative economic growth
forever in 2020 with the worst recession
in the last 60 years net emission fell
only by 9% 9% is nothing and now they're
well above the pre covid level so
mitigation with current technology is
impossible negative growth adaptation
that means let temperature go well above
two well above three and then you limit
the cost of it cost you trillions of
dollars of money give you one example
since New York you had the hurricane
Sandy and SE rise level they wanted to
protect Manan first there was a proposal
to build a wall on Manan then they say
it's going to look like a prison
ugly now they say they want to build
these levies in the water leev is near
the Verano bridge that plan is going to
cost $125 billion it's going to take 25
years it might be obsolete by the time
you do it it might not work it Deals
Only with Storm surges when water's up
because of a storm doesn't deal with sea
level rises that are permanent and if
you protect Manan you're going to flood
everything else Long Island Jersey Shore
and the rest of New York this is one
city one of the richest in the world and
40% of people live around coastal areas
so mitigation impossible adaptation too
expensive and those other solution
geoengineering like throwing Dust In The
Sky to reflect the Sun light is like
freak science and I can tell you other
constraints to do the right thing I just
give you some examples that's the gap
between what you want to do and reality
that's why there is so much green
washing there is so much green wishing
there is so much green leaf that's why
so much of ESG investment is just
and there's why there's also
lots of green flation to produce green
metals that are needed in green cars
electric vehicles electri batteries
lithium Cobalt copper zinc you need a
lot of energy and if the price of for is
high there's green inflation the price
of green metal production is expensive
and we cannot do them cheaply as well so
these are the facts that you have to
talk about but most people talk about
the platitudes if we do only so and so
so and so and so we de with climate
change and this is just one of the mega
threats on each one of them a wide r of
obstacle and constraints to doing the
right thing
[Music]
well it depends there is good media
sophis enough we can talk about the
risks and report them and discuss them
there others are not as
qualified to do so but you know in the
case of say the global financial crisis
again you have to understand the
motivations uh that led to this bubble
you know homeowners could buy homes with
very little Equity they could
borrow against their
kind of homes and the price were going
higher so they were happy the
politicians were happy because people
who could spend more their income based
on a bubble in their homes the banks
were lending the money and making
mortgages and making money on it the
investment Banks were securitizing all
these mortgage and repackaging them and
making money the rating agencies were
rating these toxic uh uh Securities of
mortgages and they were making money the
appraisers of the home were making money
by doing fees and the insurers of these
derivatives also were making money so
you had a securitization chain where
everybody in this chain was making money
households were happy politicians were
happy Wall Street was happy and
everybody lived in a bubble and once you
live in bubble you start believing
something that is not possible that home
prices can increase every year 20%
forever and this is not a bble until of
course the bubble burst so you know the
masses have their own delusions the
politician feeds on these delusions and
usually businesses and financial
institution make money out of these
delusions as well so sometimes we live
in a bubble we live in a delusion until
the bubble pops and the dream becomes a
nightmare so it happens over and over
again the story of all the financial
bubbles is about delusion of the masses
greedy investors and finers will feed
the bubble and politicians that also
make money out of it or they benefit
from these bubbles from
occurring antip
tokti to risk
[Music]
um certainly one of the consequences of
all these uh
threats and of all this
instability is the risk of social Strife
of various sorts could be labor Strife
could be violence between right and left
could be the rise of extremist uh
populist parties of extrem and right and
left could be also some of these
populist and authoritarian regimes
becoming aggressive when they have
trouble at home they find the
a sudo enemy kind of and then they go to
war like Russia did in the case of
Ukraine so definitely we see a rise in
income and wealth
inequality we see the middle class and
working class feel squeezed we see the
young generation feels that they don't
have as much Economic Opportunity that
maybe the new generation is going to be
poorer than their own parents and all of
this is leading to a backlash against
liberal democracy and you have
authoritarian populist parties of right
and left more popular you know today you
have Putin in Russia you have erdogan in
Turkey you have
Orban in U Hungary you have kazinski in
Poland monean or Neo fascist party came
to power recently in Italy the Swedish
Democrats were affect the neonazi party
are going to be part of the ruling
Coalition even in a tolerant
Sweden in Britain you got the brexit
phenomenon and all these populists and
have changed prime minister three times
in six
months uh in France we still have
democracy but one of the risk is in 2027
Leen is going to become populist you
know in power in the US of course you
have the election of Donald Trump and
his Rage Against the elites and
pretending to be a populist carrying
about white colar workers this is on the
right on the left say in Latin America
used to the case that maybe Argentina
Venezuela were the populist of the left
but look at last two or three years
populist of the left have come to power
in Mexico amlo in Peru in
Chile in
Colombia in Brazil was the choice
between the populist of the right
bolsonaro and one of the left Lula
luckily is Lula because bonaro is an
authoritarian they just tried an a atemp
against Lula the same way there was aemp
two years before in the US against the
capital and the biggest authoritarian of
all I don't know whether is of the right
or the left is of course shinpin in
China who's not anymore Secretary
General the party of president he's not
King is the Emperor he decides
everything doesn't have any more the
collective leadership and it can can
make big mistakes like authoritarian
make because authoritarians eventually
make big mistakes so we have this trend
all over the world towards populism
towards authoritarianism towards being
aggressive towards other Rivals outside
of your country that is leading also to
social Strife domestically as you know
people are unhappy about income and
wealth inequality and overall my so yeah
in different ways in different countries
is this can lead to varieties of
different forms of social thrife if not
outright
violence I let you rep your plug you've
got it yes just on your right shoulder
yes you've got
it for
[Music]
okay uh well there are two views about
what uh central banks are going to
do uh one view says that inflation has
picked is
falling and because of that they can
raise rates more slowly we'll have a
mild session a short and shallow one
maybe a couple of quarters of negative
economic growth and as you have that
recession there'll be enough slack in
labor and goods market price and wage
inflation is going to fall so by the
middle of this year the recession is
over inflation is lower and Central Bank
going to start cutting policy rates and
you got have a nice recovery of growth
and Rec of the markets in the second
half of the year so first half difficult
for the economy and the markets second
half good for economy growth and the
markets that's the conventional wisdom
the view of central banks view of most
economies The View Wall Street and the
city of
London uh I have a different
view my view is that
inflation is going to remain much higher
uh and it's going to fall but not fall
fast enough towards 2% so the issue is
not whether inflation is picked it has
picked but going from 10% to 56 is easy
going from 56 to two I think is going to
be
hard commodity prices are going to be
high Not Just Energy by others for many
reasons that's going to be
inflationary I think that the wage
inflation is going to remain high for
for many reasons labor markets are tight
unemployment is low aging of
population people retiring sooner the
great
resignation reduction in the labor force
participation rate of many people
restriction to migration labor strife
and our workers saying our reles are
falling we're going to strike we're
going to fight for our rights and the
economic policies of the government are
pro labor Pro Union Pro workers Pro
unemployed rightly so because if you
don't help them there'll be a social
Strife so you have a whole sets of
factor that imply not very high wage
inflation but say 5 6% that is
consistent with inflation well above
2% and in the service sector the most
important cost of production of course
is labor and therefore if labor
inflation is high service inflation is
going to remain
high so those factors imply inflation
falling but not towards
2% therefore the ECB cannot stop rates
only at
3% if they want to fight inflation they
have to push them to four but if you go
higher two things happen one you have a
hard Landing of the real economy the
more you raise rates the more you have a
recession and recession is slightly
longer and more protracted than a short
and shallow one secondly as you increase
interest rates the borrowing cost for
workers
households
businesses Corporation government become
higher cost of mortgages cost of auto
loans credit cards per personal loans
business loans corporate bonds
government bonds anyone who has a lot of
debt the interest is going to rise for
the last 20 years the amount of debt
relative to income was high but we had
low debt servicing costs because you had
zero policy rates negative policy rates
what they call quantitive easing or
credit easing so longterm interest rates
were low two years ago $18 trillion
equivalent of public
debt in Europe and Japan at a negative
interest rates
negative mortgages in Denmark at a
negative yield some corporations could
borrow to a negative
yield because at that time inflation was
below 2% we're fighting low inflation
with massive monetary and credit
stimulus today that part is over as
inflation has been rising interest rates
have to rise and those firms individuals
and government I call them zombies
meaning insolvent they have too much
debt relative to their ability to pay it
they're going to go bankrupt and as you
have a financial
distress that makes the recession worse
as the recession is worse and income are
falling revenues are falling then the
debt ratios become higher and become
more unsustainable and you're more
instability so you have a vicious cycle
between economic contraction and
instability and financial contraction
and instability that's why I expect not
only inflation not only recession and
stock flation but the
stationary debt crisis combination of
all these problems
[Music]
together well in the
1970s there were two first all shocks
one spacking all prices coming from the
Yum kipur war between Israel and Arab
states and embargo All Passes tripled
you got
inflation recession
stagflation and then in 79 you had
Iranian Revolution and another shock to
supply of um oil another recession and
St inflation so inflation expectation
got out of control there was a wage
price spiral because every time these
shocks did occur the reaction of the
central banks was not to raise interest
rates to fight inflation enough they
were behind the curve and inflation got
out of control was only in 79 that
inflation became such a problem that
Carter chose as the head of the FED Paul
vuler and he said do whatever it takes
in order to fight
inflation he push interest rates to 20%
% because inflation was well above
10% that led to a very severe recession
in
19882 a double deep recession and once
that recession occurred workers wages
started to fall firms did not have power
to raise prices and he was able to break
the back of inflation
expectations and fight inflation and
push it down to lower level but it cost
a lot of in terms of very severe
recession for over two years even that
aemp now the problem today is as
follows like the 1970s we have negative
Supply
shocks the impact of covid on production
of goods Supply chains supply of labor
the impact of the Russian invasion of
Ukraine on commodity prices the impact
of the zero covid policy of China until
recently on Global Supply
chains but in the
1970s we had inflation and stock
inflation but we did not have a debt
crisis in advanced economies because
debt ratio private and public were low
100% of GDP today are 4 20% of GDP four
times
highers after the global financial
crisis
we had the debt problem too much debt of
households mortgages and borrowing and
lending by Banks but we had a demand
shock not a supply shock a credit crunch
collapse of demand implied deflation and
once we had deflation we could ease
monetary policy fiscal policy and credit
to help the real economy because we had
the problem of little inflation not
enough
today we have the worst of the
1970s because we have the negative
Supply shocks that stock flation but we
have four times as much debt as the 70s
and we are entering a recession not
cutting policy rates but increasing them
because we have now inflation so you
have an inflation problem you have a
stock infation problem and you have a
debt
problem excessive debt as well now if
you're not willing to deal with the debt
Problem by raising taxes or cutting
spending the solution is the inflation
tax you monetize the deficit you cause
inflation and inflation when is not
expected reduces the real value of
nominal debt of long
duration at fixed interest rates the
real value of the debt is reduced by
inflation effectively it's like a tax on
Capital a tax on Savers and creditors
and transfer money and income to debors
and borrowers by the inflation tax
that's will be the solution to a thatb
problem effectively we're going to have
higher
inflation because we are at that trap
there is so much debt in the system that
if you raise interest rates enough to
fight inflation not only cause a
recession you also cause a debt crisis
and faced with a risk of a
economic and financial crash central
banks they talk tough hawkish they're
going to wimp out they're going to Blink
they're going to become doish because
they cannot afford having a severe
economic and financial Cris
so we end up with higher levels of
inflation on a more permanent basis I
think that's the outcome of it the way
you deal with it is the part of list
resistance from a political point of
view
[Music]
well he received the prize because he
was a scholar of the Great
Depression and during the Great
Depression the stock market crash of 29
became a depression because we allowed
many farmers many businesses many banks
millions of them to
collapse many of them were illiquid they
didn't have enough liquidity they were
not necessarily bankrupt but by not
providing them with support monetary and
credit a problem of liquidity became a
problem of insolvency they went bankrupt
and something they started a financial
shock became a Great Depression it was a
collapse of demand deflation and so on
so when the global financial crisis
occurred the lesson was we should do
enough monetary fiscal and credit easing
to avoid this Great Recession from
becoming Great Depression 2.0
and there is a logic to doing a back
stop of some parts of the private and
public
sector however the buildup of debt has
occurred from 100% of GDP in the 70s to
420 today is that every time there is a
bubble we don't stop it and people keep
on over borrowing and the bubble leads
to more debt and leverage and then when
the crash occurs we say oh my God there
is a systemic risk there is be a
financial crisis a depression and then
we do
easing that makes then the borrowing
cost cheap and leads to another cycle of
borrowing even more so we don't stop the
bubble in the good times and then we try
to protect people from the effects of a
collapse of a bubble in bed times and
this asymmetric response
implies more bubbles more leverage more
debt more staking in good times and then
bailing out everybody in bad times that
causes a moral hazard what people called
moral azard that if you are protected
and insured you're going to take more
risk than you should so it leads to a
bias of buildup of excessive
that and Ben
banki wrote paper
on why we should not try to prick a
bubble in good times he says too
dangerous and he said when the bubble
becomes excessive and goes down burst
then we have to protect the system from
cotal collapse like the Great Depression
but not doing anything in good times and
then dealing with the bubble exposed
create these biases towards more bubbles
more debt more leverage so that's his
intellectual mistake take he learned
well some lessons of the great
oppression but he didn't learn the
lessons of what it means to have too
much thatb leverage and loose monetary
policy
[Music]
foral um well first of all I met her on
many occasion she's a very Savvy policy
maker she has a lot of
experience she was a finance minister in
France she headed the international
monetary fund now the European Central
Bank she's not an economist by training
she's a lawyer but she's learned a lot
of economics and the connection between
economics and policy and politics so
she's a high
quality policy makers like every policy
makers uh she's subject to constraint
now policy makers are not stupid they're
not evil they're not dumb they don't
want to cause
damage the problem the ECB is facing
today is that uh inflation went up a lot
in the Euro Zone in part because of
these negative Supply shocks but in part
also because the monetary fiscal and
credit stimulus after CID was too much
too much for too long that was the
policy
mistake however right now you have a
dilemma if you raise interest rates
enough to fight inflation you isk
causing a recession and a Severe
recession and if you don't increase
interest rates enough to fight
inflation you you risk having a de
anchoring of inflation and inflation
expectations and a price in wage spiral
that leads to high inflation like the
70s so them if you do them if you don't
but now there is a additional layer of U
stress as you increase interest rates as
I said many government Euro Zone some
banks some governments some corporations
some household some workers have a lot
of debt and as you raise interest rates
there is a risk that some of them go
bankrupt they become insolvent and that
financial crash damag the real economy
and a weaker real economy makes even
more of a Deb problem so there's also a
risk of financial
instability now the ECB now has created
this new instrument is called TPI
transmission protection
instrument that says that if the
spread of any member of the Euro Zone
goes high too much causing the risk of a
debt problem for
government as long as the rise in the
spread is due only to panic to market
dynamics is not is not justified by the
economic fundamentals then the ECB could
go and buy the bonds of that country and
prevent a disorderly crisis from
occurring however in practice the reason
why the spreads of a country may rise is
not just because people are irrational
in the markets but because maybe there
is loose fiscal policy uh there is lack
of economic reforms look what happened
in the United Kingdom when they the
fiscal stimulus and then they were
punished by the markets with their
spread Rising and their currency falling
in
value so the ECB can help countries are
doing the right thing but they just bad
luck because of irrational investors but
if the reason why the spread goes up is
because of their own policy mistakes
then the CV would not be able to help
them and then you have a risk of a
disorderly Deb crisis so that's another
layer of complication in the decision
making of the European Central
Bank it's not easy
[Music]
C
well whenever there is excessive
debt uh there are potentially many
solutions each one of them has benefits
as some cost of course the best solution
to that problem is high economic growth
because a debt is a ratio between the
level of the debt and some income if
your income Rises your debt becomes more
sustainable the that to income ratio
Falls of course that's wishful thinking
because when debt is high growth becomes
lower and when growth is lower the debt
ratio becomes higher so you end up in
the Vicious Circle some people say if
your debt is too much save spend
less and uh and tighten your
belt at the individual level that works
if I have too much debt and I spend less
I save more I can reduce my debts but if
everybody in the economy
spends less saves more that makes the
recession worse and as the recession is
worse income Falls and your debt to
income ratio becomes higher that's what
canes called the Paradox of thrift the
Paradox of saving what is individually
rational collectively may be actually
the wrong response now if you borrow in
a foreign currency
and you have too much debt you have no
choice but to default and then to
restructure your debt negotiate a
reduction of your debt that's what
emerging markets do the difference is
however that in advanced economies like
us and Europe that borrow in their own
currencies you can reduce the real value
of your nominal debt by having a
surprise inflation because inflation
implies that your borrowing cost in real
terms are reduced and the real value of
your debt is lower so unexpected
inflation is a form of default you're
still taxing Savers and creditors and
transferring well to the debtor and
borrowers but it's not done through
formal default it's done through the
inflation tax another solution can be
Financial repression you force the banks
to hold your debt of the government and
if the demand for the is high the
interest rate is lower but a tax on the
financial system another solution is you
tax the wealty you have a weal taxation
you expropriate their wealth and then
you use it to pay down your debt but
that's again a form of taxing the
creditors and the Savers and
transferring money to the borrowers so
they're all variant of the same default
monetization inflation capital taxation
expropriation Financial
repression outright default and rest
structuring there are variants of the
same idea when there's too much thatt so
you have to choose your poison figure
out which one of them is less damaging
and it depends on many different
variables
no can you explain it in English okay
well I'm not sure if taking a little of
Poison every day it's a protects you
against the poison makes you more immune
or is a small slow death I think it
probably is more the latter rather than
the former one is like boiling a frog
slowly you boil it slowly but eventually
you kill the frog with a slow motion
death
well it was not just Janet Allen uh the
Fed
ACB pretty much all advanced economies
policy makers did not see this inflation
coming on one side they they made a
mistake on the other side also many
Economist and Wall Street made the same
mistake because for 20 years the problem
in advanced economy was not high
inflation was that we had a target of 2%
and inflation was below 2% sometimes
close to zero after the global financial
crisis
deflation at the beginning of the covid
crisis also had deflation because the
fall in demand was greater than the fall
in
Supply and during the global financial
crisis we didn't have enough monetary
and fiscal stimulus and the recovery was
anemic growth picked up but very
slowly the
unemployment rate remained high and fell
only slowly so when the covid shock
occurred everybody whether on the right
or the left said we made a mistake
during the global financial crisis we
didn't have enough monetary and fiscal
and credit stimulus this time around
since the shock looks bigger let's do a
massive
stimulus the problem was that one the
stimulus was a order of magnitude three
four times more as a sh GDP than what
they did 10 years before secondly the
global financial crisis was a severe
crisis the last two or three years while
the covid shock in terms of recession
was from February of 2020 until May June
was a very short and shallow recession
lasted barely maximum two quarters and
with the reopening of the economy as we
flatten the curve and with the massive
fiscal monetary and credit stimulus the
economy started to recover fast so the
stimulus became one too much too long
and excessive on one side secondly in
the short run demand fell more than
Supply but then demand recovered even
the stimulus but people did not realize
because they had not seen negative
Supply shock since the 70s that covid
was also a negative Supply shock
reducing the production of goods and
services reducing the supply of labor
creating bottlenecks in Global Supply
chains this was the first shock and then
in 2022 last year you had another
negative Supply shock the surprise
policy makers the Russian invasion of
Ukraine that increase oil prices Natural
Gas
food fertilizers and Industrial Metals
and three there was another third
negative Supply shock that was the zero
covid policy of China the shut down
production in China and created
additional Global Supply bottlenecks so
inflation got under control because of a
combination of bad policies lose
monetary fiscal and credit eing but also
bad luck at least three negative
aggregate supply shocks so policy makers
made mistakes but they have to also try
to figure out why they made those
[Music]
mistakes
mean ven
[Music]
um well Financial Market have both uh
positive functions of taking savings and
allocating them to the right
investment projects financing things
that are
useful like uh mortgages so you can buy
a home or various types of personal
loans to smooth shocks to your income or
give business loans that allow
businesses to grow but like everything
else uh if that borrowing becomes
excessive if the credit criteria and
standards become loose if you allow too
much debt and too much leverage and too
much
risk-taking then you're feeding a bubble
because people borrow money to buy
assets the value assets goes higher then
they can use those assets as a
collateral to borrow more and you enter
into a credit and an asset bubble in
which then people become arogant become
raking there is fraud and all of these
eventually leads to a boom and a bubble
and then eventually a bust and a crash
and you're right human beings are always
going to be greedy some of them
especially in financial markets it's not
just Financial market today uh in last
few years a young generation of young
genes hopeless skilless jobless
incom less they do day trading they buy
Mimi stocks they buy crypto believing
they can become rich overnight no one
has become rich overnight one person
maybe out of a million everybody else
loses their money so it's not just a
small group of Wall Street speculators
and greedy people that are the travel
now as we come across the board
everybody's gambling with money and
having this type of delusion
of course the job of monetary
policy the job of Supervisors and
Regulators of the financial system would
be to stop the
bubble be before it becomes excessive
you can do it by raising interest rates
you can do it by credit controls you by
can do it by limiting leverage and a
whole range of Prudential
policies of avoiding excessive credit B
bubbles they cause asset bubbles the
trouble is that in Good Times
implementing these policies is
hard the politician and the borrowers
complain and say hey you're not letting
me invest to borrow and I'm doing it for
good
reasons and The Regulators often are
captured by Wall Street and by industry
sometimes the politicians are corrupt
and whenever there's bubble we find some
story on why there is a major new
revolution
technology uh the internet the railroads
crypto whatever that justifies investing
and leveraging the bubble and of course
those are fantasies and they end up in
tears but in the meanwhile the bubble
gets out of control until it goes Bast
and then the next one comes so these are
cycles that in principle we control we
could control with tight money High
interest rates Capital controls credit
controls credential regulation
supervision of banks Shadow banks
financial system reducing toxic
derivatives reducing toxic
financialization and so on and so on but
we don't do it so we go through these
Cycles over and over again
[Music]
crypto
yeah I've been personally a skeptic of
uh cryptocurrencies and a Critic of them
already starting in
201617 and I kept my view that where
most of them a scum a Ponzi game
criminal fraud a bubble that's going to
event
burst and look at the last year alone in
the last 12 months uh even Bitcoin lost
80% of his value going from 69,000 to 16
ethereum has lost more than
80% the other top 10 of them lost
between 80 to
90% And of course tens of thousands of
these icos initial coin offerings were a
scam to begin with people stealing the
money to buy cars Lamborghini Villas
boats planes in the Caribbean Miami
literally scum and criminal Behavior 99%
of it is this way secondly calling them
crypto
currencies is a is a misn no they're not
money they're not
currency they're they're not a unit of
account
cuz nothing is priced in
Bitcoin they're not a scalable means of
payment because with Bitcoin you can do
seven transactions per second with the
VISA Network you can do 50,000
transaction per
second they're not a stable store of
value because the value of Bitcoin can
go up or down 10 20% overnight that's
why even the crypto conference
don't accept payment of their fees in
Bitcoin because the entire profit margin
of the conference can be wiped out
overnight and finally they are not a
single numer single rer means that I
need a unit of count so I can compare
the price of bread as opposed to the
price of of meat the relative price
between two so you need a single
numerator in a world of tokenization
where there are thousands of tokens if I
need a Pepsi token to buy Pepsi Cola and
a Coca token to buy Coca-Cola I cannot
tell anymore even the relative price
between cocacola and Pepsi between bread
and meat is like going back to literally
to
barter even even The Flintstones you
know the cartoon story about Stone Age
people they had a more advanced monetary
system than crypto because they had a
single numer they're using shell the
shell where the unit of account so you
can tell the price of Bride versus the
price of meat in crypto you're back to
barter so calling them currencies money
they're not doesn't make any sense
they're not even
assets usually asset as some
income stocks give you
dividends bonds give you coupon
payments bonds you give interest on it a
a business loan a bank loan gives you
interest real estate gives you
rent or you have the rental service of
owning your home Commodities oil energy
food give you the services of that
these guys don't have any income now
gold doesn't have income but it had
utility jewelry and uses industry like
gold silver are used for production of
various types of goods and
services take
Bitcoin doesn't have
income doesn't have any using industry
doesn't have any use utility nobody's
wearing Bitcoin jewelry actually some
tacky people wear them but they're
really ugly there's not going to be
Bitcoin jewelry becoming popular and
therefore you cannot even value Bitcoin
because you need a stream either of
income or a stream of use or a stream
utility that you can do to do the
discounted value of it so you can price
the value of an assets so it's
impossible to price these things that's
why some people say Bitcoin is going to
be million and now people say it's going
to be zero my view is the fundamental
value of Bitcoin is zero zero actually
it's negative it's not zero because
Bitcoin has a huge negative
environmental externality uses so much
energy to produce it more than the
Netherlands or Argentina that if there
was the right carbon tax on bitcoin the
value of Bitcoin wouldn't be zero will
be negative given the carbon tax to deal
with the externality of Bitcoin so
they're not
currencies they're not
assets they are scams bunch of crooks
schals
frosters tax evaders terrorists and
other people doing illegal activities
like human trafficking are using them
that's the only use of it for illegal
activities
so they're a total scam total
criminality and SBF SBF the head of FTX
is not the
exception is the rule they're all scum
they're all pony games and they're all
criminal and Crooks they should all end
up in
jail they are not all
criminals almost all of them frankly
um I think the two things are actually
correlated because um what happened in
Us in Anglo-Saxon country was that for a
long time the income of people were not
Rising enough compared to their own
demand expectation of spending and
consumption as they say Americans could
not keep up with the Joneses every
family were comparing themselves with
the neighbors and say they look richer
they have the AO the bigger car home
whatever so what was the solution that
was given in the Anglo-Saxon country is
what we call democratization of Finance
all let you to have many credit cards I
let you to borrow to buy your uh car I
let you borrow to for your student loan
I let you borrow as much as you want to
buy a home and put very little equity
and as the value of your home goes
higher because everybody's borrowing
then you can borrow even more is What's
called the home Equity withdrawal the
value of home is higher let me take a
loan against the higher value so I can
spend more than my income because your
income was not sufficient to finance all
your spending so effectively use your uh
home like a ATM machine and borrowing
against it and afford the lifestyle you
couldn't afford it so the mortgage
problem and the consumption problem are
two sides of the same problem that
you're using your home as a ATM machine
you borrow against it to finance
consumption above your income so the
mortgage bubble was also a consumption
bubble and when the mortgage bubble went
bust the consumption bubble goes bust so
and the fundamental problem is there is
income and wealth inequality real income
are not Rising enough the cost of
Education of health care of Pensions of
buying a home form of services is rising
and people are desperate and when they
are desperate they finance their excess
consumption compared their income by
borrowing and you have a Deb bubble and
you make money cheap they borrow even
more until the bubble
[Music]
burst well uh I'm in principle in favor
of uh free trade of
globalization of migration of capital of
Labor of more trading Goods in
Services uh in data information
technology the country that integrated
globally have done well suppose you were
taking all the 27 or 28 countries of the
European Union if there had not been the
European Union there'll be small
economies small market and they would
not be able to grow as fast as having
foreign markets within Europe or
globally so most countries in Europe and
the Euro Zone have been actually
benefiting from
globalization look at China or India
they are so poor and they start becoming
less poor when they opened up to the
global economy and they joined the
global markets the global labor
Supply look at example North Korea and
South Korea at the time of Korean War
the north was much richer than the South
that the natural resources that the
manufacturing Korea didn't have anything
but Kore invested in their human capital
education skills and now is an advanced
economy while people are still Starving
in North Korea that is a outar country
of course however trade globalization
migration leads to winners and
losers if you are a low value added blue
collar worker in advanced economies in a
labor intensive sector of the economy
manufacturing light then your jobs and
your income can be threatened by Cheap
Goods coming from China or other
Emerging Markets but that's the natural
churn of an economic uh system and of
course we should have helped those who
lost their jobs by giving them training
education so they could go into other
jobs but we failed we have trade creates
enough economic gains that you can tax
those that are winners transfer income
or skills to those we were left behind
and you can still make everybody better
off but we didn't do that the winners
got more of the share of the benefits
while those who were losers or left
behind were never helped and that was
the beginning of the backlash by blue
collar workers and others against trade
and globalization and migration and so
on so in principle globalization is a
good idea but you have to deal with the
distributional effects of trade
otherwise you can make a good chunk of
your country worse off rather than
better off
[Music]
yeah
yeah class
action for
[Music]
yes there is a possibility that there be
class action lawsuits against energy
companies in the same way there were
similar kind of lawsuits against the
tobacco
companies that's a Potential Threat to
some of their profits and their
earnings uh but I would say that um we
don't know yet whether those will be
successful and what the the fees that
they have to pay will be or
fines and I would say in the short run
what The Old Company worry more about is
that U since Energy prices are high the
profits of this old company have risen
very sharply and now in many
countries there is this view that we
should tax them these extraordinary
profits
because uh they're excessive and we
should use the taxation of those profits
to transfer income to households or
businesses that hurt by high energy
prices now there is a logic to trying to
tax the super profits that are abnormal
that's the argument for it but then the
counter argument is that in a world in
which uh Energy prices are high because
there is not enough uh supply of energy
if you tax them and already all company
are under investing into new production
of fossil fuels they may produce even
less and then the supply constraint
becomes higher and then the cost of
energy could also become higher so
finding the right response is not so
simple it's easy to blame Big Oil you're
rich you make all this money let me tax
your way
then you have to think about the the
consequence of it for
example I'm all in favor of dealing with
global climate
change and because we worry about the
emissions coming from fossil fuels we're
bashing big oil and we're telling
shareholders stakeholders tell your
companies to
underinvested Fuels and go into
renewable and we're telling the banks
try to not fund big old company if they
don't invest into renewable now all that
pressure shareholder stakeholders
governments social Society Banks implies
that for last 5 to 10 years big old
companies especially the private ones
have underinvested into new capacity of
new fields of fossil fuels so the supply
of fossil fuel is
falling but the supply of renewable
energy is not Rising fast enough to
compensate for the fall in the supply
and capacity of fossil fuel so now we
have a structural lack of supply of
energy so even beef even before the
Russian invasion of Ukraine Brent that
is an index of all prices was close to
$100 per barrel even before so it was
not just the Russian invasion of Ukraine
that caused the spike in all prices in
part was also this
underinvestment in fossil fuel capacity
because of bashing and going after Big
Oil so those are some of the side
effects of well-intended policies that
have
unintended consequences
[Music]
say you know both cop in
Glasgow and cop in shalma Shake were
were a failure and not only because they
had of some old company may have too
much influence because most Corporation
not just old company they do these net
zero plans but their net zero plans are
written by their communication and PR
departments they're not written by the
managers or the scientists so everybody
has to pretend that 20 years from now
we're going to go to zero they write a
white paper there's no substance but
this way they save their face and of
course they do little cosmetic here and
there to save energy and on reducing
their carbon footprint but as I said is
all green washing is all green wishing
so even if all the commitments of the
last to cops were to be made and that's
a big if because neither us nor Europe
nor Emerging Market are going to do what
they said but even with the current
commitments we're going to go to a rise
in temperature tempatures there is not
1.5 is not two two degrees is current
level where towards a trajectory of
2.4 even if we do everything we promised
and since we're not going to do
everything we promised the number by the
end of this Century may be plus
three 1.5 is bad two is ugly three is a
disaster we're on the way towards plus
three let's be realistic about it and
everybody is
greenwashing you know the Davos forum
and I have gone there many years not
every year is one of the many forums and
there tons of other ones where global
leaders get together and they discuss
global economic issues now do they
resolve problems no but other Forum any
conference in the world you talk you
debate stuff you try to figure out
Solutions but these are not Forum of
taking decisions the decision are taken
at the national level or International
level in other types of fora like IMF
World Bank un and so on on that in my
view having people get to
together and talk to each other rather
than making word to each other is a good
idea is a good idea having global
leaders economic political religious
cultural and so on is a good idea and of
course over the next last few decades
the we has been sensitive to the fact
that are social issues so there are
social entrepreneurs and there are
leaders of various types of
Environmental
organizations and others who care about
Labor rights and so on so they try to be
more representative of a broader
spectrum of views on all of these issues
so it's a good forum that plenty of
other ones are as good where people get
together and discuss is more of a talk
shop rather than a action
shop uh is useful but I don't believe
that any individual alone any Forum any
organization can resolve Global problems
uh you know on the uh Global pandemic
the World Health Organization the
wh did not
succeed on issues of trade we're going
towards protectionis de globalization
and the WTO the World Trade Organization
has limited
powers the UN has limited powers in
enforcing Global Security the IMF and
the World Bank do a good job but they
have limited powers so we don't have yet
institutions of global governance that
are powerful enough to enforce Global
decision making Global rules and in fact
is now a backlash against globalization
against globalist against supranational
organization because they claim they
don't have the Democratic legitimacy
they take away National sovereignty but
you know we live in a world where the
problems are global climate change
pandemic Economic Security Financial
Security global Military
security impact of AI climate change and
you name it so for Global problems you
need Global governance we need more
Global governance not less and
unfortunately now there is a more of a
national istic backlash I want to
protect my country my workers my firms
and if you do that you go towards
protectionism but you know my taxes on
your exports that are my import reduce
your exports but if you retaliate
against me your tariffs reduce my
exports to you and if you start a war of
retaliation increasing import tax on
both sides everybody is worth off and we
have a worse World rather than a better
world so of course globalization and
trade has some cost we have to deal with
them growth has to be sustainable has to
be inclusive has to deal with inequality
but trade protectionism is not the right
solution
[Music]
well some of the cost from climate
change are the loss of uh almost half of
animal and uh uh uh
plants in the
planet uh because we have this
anthropomorphic view where everything is
centered around human and sapience and
we don't care as much about the welfare
of animal and plants we don't vote we
don't have a say of course damaging the
planet destroying the plants and the
Animals it has a number of side effects
that are cost even to human beings
and destroying the planet creates damage
hurricanes rising sea levels droughts
floods wildfires that have a huge
economic cost even for the humans let
alone for the animals but as I pointed
out before doing something about global
climate change is subject to a huge
range of political domestic and
international constraints that prevents
us from doing uh the right
thing well the big picture point I want
to highlight is the following
one we have had
75 years of relative peace progress and
prosperity say after
1945 and we think that the future is
going to be like the near past and we
projected this
way however I think that's a mistake for
a number of reasons first of all even in
those 75 years the period between
1945 and until the early
1980s was very different from the last
years and I'll give you the following
description I'm old enough you're
younger than me I'm 64 was born in the
50s and I grew up 60 70 early 80s
between Middle East and Europe until I
came to us now when I grew up I never
worried about war among great powers and
nuclear winter the
next to China very little I never
worried about climate change
temperatures were barely above prer
level I never worried about pandemics
never even heard about them last one was
1918 Spanish
Flu I never worried about AI destroying
most jobs there was no AI yeah there was
AI old Theory AI
winter I never worried about de
globalization and protectionist with
integration of Europe
NAFTA Gat WTO we even had hyper
globalization with China Russia India
emergy market joining the global
markets I never worried about debt
crisis debt ratio private and public
were low growth was high so there were
no debt crisis I never worried about
implicit debt un funded debt coming from
aging of population lots of young people
workers and their taxes paying for the
benefits for smaller number of elderly
today is the
opposite I never worried about
depression yeah there were economic
cycle some recessions they were mild in
the 70s yes we had stock flation but it
was followed by 30 years of great
moderation we didn't have really big
financial crisis boom Babble Bast and
crash was regulation supervision of the
banks Capital controls Financial
repression and we didn't have the toxic
leverage financialization derivatives we
have today economic Cycles were stable
Financial cycle were stable and finally
we used to live in Liberal democracies
yeah were center right center left
disagreeing but not the kind of extreme
polarization partisanship that you have
between extreme populist party of the
extreme right or left now becoming more
popular coming to power so this is the
world I lived you fast forward to today
we have a risk of War among Global
powers and a nuclear war not just a
convential war climate change is a
disaster pandemics are occurring more
frequently why why there was known
between 1918 and 1980s now we have HIV a
mares SARS swine flu bird flu zika Ebola
covid-19 it's only matter of time
because as we destroy the animal
ecosystem those animals that carry the
pathogens pangol in bats get closer to
livestock and humans and then the
zoonotic transmission from animal to
becomes more frequent so there'll be
even worse pandemic in the future now we
have the risk of AI destroying most jobs
increasing
inequality permanent uh unemployment is
technological we have de globalization
and protectionism we have bigger
economic Cycles we have private and
public debt explosive implicit that
coming from aging explosive and now
authoritarian po of right and left are
coming to power so the last 20 years
have been showing the emergence of these
Mega threats that did not even EX in the
golden 30 40 years between
1945 and the early 80s additional
point the period before 1945 we had 30
years they look like
today in spite of the first
industrialization in spite of the first
era of globalization we did not prevent
World War I and after world I we had the
Spanish flu then where the stock market
crash of 29 then we had the beginning of
the Great Depression then we had
inflation
hyperinflation
deflation trade Wars currency
Wars financial crisis debt crisis
default unemployment
25% economic meltdown and then the Nazis
with Hitler came to power in Germany the
fascist with musolini came power in
Italy Franco came to power in Spain
and the militarist aggressive C power in
Japan and then we had the World War II
and then with the Holocaust and only
after that we created institutions that
gave us relative peace and prosperity
for a period of time and now we Mega
threats
however has bad as the ugly 30 years
between 1914 and 1945 where there are
four Mega threats that did not exist
then and exist today at that time you
didn't have to worry about climate
change right it was not an issue you
didn't worry about AI destroying jobs
there was not even a computer let alone
AI you didn't have to worry about
implicit debt of government because
Social Security System pensions had been
barely created and most people were
dying before they're getting their first
pension check and as ugly as World War I
and World World War II where there were
mostly conventional Wars was only at the
end of World War II that luckily was the
US rather Nazi Germany who got the bomb
and then the Americans used the bomb on
hoshima and nagazaki to stop and end
World War II this time around if there
was a conflict between great powers that
war is not going to be unconventional
it's going to start conventional and
it's going to become rapidly unconv
evental so the risk of a war that
becomes a nuclear winter for the entire
humanity is a new risk so compared to
the 30s and the 40s today the things are
having Mega threats they did not even
exist in those 30 years were ugly and
nasty so we cannot take progress for
granted we cannot assume that the future
is going to be near past we are living
like zombies we are sleep walking into
disaster there we push the snooze button
we are not addressing this problem
they're getting worse day by day they're
all interconnect each other and unless
we change it this is not just the end of
our incomes of our jobs or saving or El
could the end of the planet the end of
humanity could be destruction of our own
species that is a risk we're facing
today I'm not saying it's going to
happen but we have to be aware of the
problem start to address it it
individually collectively National level
International level and the time to act
is now we're wasted time the time to act
is now if we don't we're going to face
dystopia instability chaos and
disaster that's my main
message for
[Music]
you know when covid occurs many people I
knew even friends Escape New York I live
in New York they went to Miami they went
to the Hampton they went to Upstate I
spent all of covid literally every
single day in New York I never even went
once to Miami me of the htons for 3
years until it
ended because you know there was a
lockdowns I could have gotten sick I
could have ended up in hospital I could
have died and then there were
demonstration BLM rightly so there was
even violence there was riots there was
even lootings most of the shops in my
neighborhood were being boarded up
because they were looting and breaking
them and so on I didn't ask AP you have
to face the reality you are in if there
was another Global pandemics New York is
going to be Ground Zero of it because
globalization lots of people coming in
of course was a ground zero it's going
to happen again if there was a nuclear
war the first nuclear weapon go to New
York Washington Beijing and Moscow
everybody in New York is going to
die uh climate change is increasing sea
level rising
most of Manan is going to be underwater
hurricane Sunday destroy the good chunk
of Manan there'll be other hurricanes
but you know you canot escape in a cave
Upstate you cannot go and buy a piece of
land in New Zealand hoping they're going
to avoid this mess because it's going to
hit you one way or another plus if most
humanity is destroyed you want to live
I'd rather to live my life being New
York being engaged socially politically
and try to resolve this problem hoping
they don't happen because if does happen
I'd rather not live I'd rather die like
everybody else rather to escape
somewhere else so the reality is that
the way to deal with these things to be
engaged to talk about them to take
action and to live your life as it is
rather than trying to live in a
Dreamland where it's not a dream it's
going to become a nightmare and you
cannot escape from reality and by the
way during covid since before Co I was
spending half of my time driving around
the world I didn't have time for my
friends during Co I learned to cook and
every Friday night I had Shabbat dinner
and we have a nice conversation Jeffer
son where we discuss some important
topic with a common conversation and all
the musician in New York during covid
could not play live so my home was on a
few places with live music and jum
session so we created you know Shabbat
dinner and community and kindred spirits
and friends who actually survive and
thrive during covid we didn't escape the
city and create a community so the
silver lining of Co was better human
relationship better friendship better
sense of community less sense of
anonymity some people became more
Anonymous more lonely I created my
friends community so even at the
personal level became an occasion for
growth and becoming more compassionate
and more caring and more
aware for
[Music]
you know first of all I always say I'm
not Dr Doom I'm not always more
pessimistic actually the two major
events in the last decade where I was
much more optimistic than consensus in
15 sorry 15 the consensus on Wall Street
was that greit will occur Greek exit
from the Euro Zone all of Wall Street
Goldman Sachs City their Baseline was
grexit I spent many months going to
Brussels Berlin Rome aans Paris I talked
to all the policy makers and I realizing
that game of chicken between Greece and
the tra Greece did not have a good hand
and would have to Blink and I realize
that the $200 billion bailout of Greece
was the carrot in addition to the sticks
of austerity reform will lead them to
then stay in the Euro Zone and I realize
that uh geopolitically while the
minister of Treasury of Germany shely
wanted Greece to go angal realized this
was the year of the Syrian crisis and
the refugees that they GRE had left the
Euro Zone then all these refugees could
come from Turkey to Greece to Europe so
it was also a political reason for
keeping Greece in the Euro Zone and when
I contacted all those dots I said grexit
will not occur when everybody else
believe grexit will occur and then a
dominant effect will lead to the rest of
us on collapse same thing happened a
year later people were worried in Davos
January and February of 2016 of a hard
Landing of China it started in August
September of 15 then it became worse in
January February of 16 stock market
crashed every thought oh my God Chinese
market are crashing stock market us is
crashing more than 20% repeat of the
global financial crisis hard Landing of
China and everybody in Davos was asking
me is going to be the hard Landing of
China a repeat of the global financial
crisis I said no China is not going to
have a soft land Landing is not going to
have a hard Landing it's going to be
bumpy they have the resources to back
stop the system and try to control the
crisis not going to be another Financial
Cris so on the two major events of the
last decade where the consensus was
grexit collapse of the Euro Zone and
collapse of China another Global
meltdown I said the opposite I was much
more optimistic than
consensus additionally when I speak
about the thems of my book
today I'm not talking about aliens
coming from Mars taking over the Earth
I'm not talking about asteroids hitting
the
planet I'm talking about threats that
everybody recognizes hundreds of books
on climate change on
geopolitical depression about pandemics
about financial threats about uh de
globalization all of these things are
actually reasonably obvious what I do
value added I connect the dots you know
I call the mega threats other people
call it poly crisis the head of the MF
calls it Confluence of calamities
yesterday the uh we did their Global
risk report same idea connection of all
these different crisis that I discuss so
the ideas are there I connect the dots
and I look at from an economic point of
view at what are the cost of all these
Mega threats and how each one of these
economic factors affects these Mega
threats and how they're connect to each
other but I'm not speaking about science
fiction this is not science fiction at
all these are threats that everybody
agrees exist then some people say some
are more risky some are less risky some
going to happen in the far future some
of them are policy solutions that are
more likely rather than less likely we
can agree or disagree to the extent of
it but I've not heard anybody saying
that none of these Mega threat exist all
of them do exist the question is how
severe they are and can we wake up and
can we address them before it's too late
that's the only question that is matter
of
[Music]
debate um we have seen for the last few
decades an increase in income and wealth
inequalities between hav and have not
those who go ahead and those who are
left
behind is happening in advanced
economies especially
Anglo-Saxons but it's happening also in
China in India and emerging markets and
some of the backlash against liberal
democracy comes from this rise in income
and wealth
inequality it's dangerous
because when there is excessive
inequality it leads to social Strife to
violence to Civil Wars sometimes the
revolution or to the rise to power of
extremist populists of the right and the
left that are not even able to reduce
that
inequality so I think that uh these
divisions are dangerous and eventually
lead to either domestic or external
violence so
the rise in income and wealth inequality
is one of the threats that we have to
address the unfortunate problem is that
usually policies of taxation of the
wealthy redistribution to the poor do
not significantly reduce inequality
historically inequality has been only
reduced when you have Revolution Wars
famines pestilence but that's one in
which even the rich die or get sick or
lose their wealth is not the best way of
reducing inequality so the question we
have to ask ourselves are there policies
that are progressive they can reduce
inequality before violence reduces
inequality I'm not sure we have the
right answer for that
[Music]
uh tax evasion alone is not a mega
threat but tax evasion tax avoidance is
one of the many reasons why inequality
is rising is rising because of trade
because of globalization because of
migration because of technological
innovation that is capital intensive
skill buyas labor saving but is also
because the elites have economic
political Financial power they change
the regulations they change the tax laws
to their favor capital is more mobile
than labor and capital can move to
Offshore Financial Centers they don't
tax properly or allow some Corporation
some rich individuals to avoid taxes or
to do a across the board tax
so that's that's a
problem well uh I'm not a religious Jew
I'm secular but I think that you know
the the Bible especially the Old
Testament is still a great book uh there
are lots of act
uh especially Genesis stories of
humanity of tragedy some people say lots
of violence sex incest and and other
types of drama that is human but there
is about moral values as well and how
you create a nation and how you create a
better Humanity so even a secular person
I think can find the Old Testament as
something worth reading
uh secondly you know when I was growing
up I would read a lot of literature
especially in high school great European
literatures not just Italian or German
but even French and all the great novels
of uh of say even French literature one
that really was on my favorite was the
the novel of stendal especially leloir
there's a great story not of love and
passion but also of society politics and
the combination between the personal the
social and political so that's a that's
a classic novel of understanding a
society not just individual dramas so
it's a fascinating there many other
great novels but definitely that one is
a one that affected
me
um I would say that when I was young
before I want to become an economist was
fascinated by psychology
psychoanalysis and I read the one of the
first books of sigon Freud the
interpretation of dreams and every time
I had the dream I would write it down
and try to analyze it so before I became
an economist I thought I'd become a
psychoanalyst and from Freud I started
reading the books and the work of the
Frankfurt F School uh like adoro
oimr Maru and the mixture of ponal and
Marx
and then from there I became a pseudo
Marxist probably was more of a limousine
socialist but then from marks I learned
about canes and I became a mainstream
Economist so I write to mainstream
economics via sigon Freud the Frankfurt
School
Maru and then Marx and then from there I
reached the understanding of economic
system more in a more mainstream way so
[Music]
yeah I teach young people and they tell
me given all these Mega
threats you know what I can
do uh and I say many things of course
dealing with climate change requires
Collective choices but each of us we can
make small sacrifices individually to
reduce our carbon Footprints lots of
them they're not easy but we could so we
cannot just wait for the government to
do it we have to do it and we have to
also organize ourselves politically and
socially organization social Society if
not political party so you have to be
engaged you can resolve things
individually first two you have to study
and you have to make sure you're not
going to become obsolete because of AI
machine learning robotic automation I
would say you should major in probably
stem science engineering math
technology computer science but you also
should have a minor in Liberal Arts you
have to think critically read well write
well and those kind of soft skills are
going to allow you to change jobs
because over the life time you're never
going to have the same job in the same
industry with the same company forever
like it used to be the case you have to
be flexible Nimble to change job so
combination understanding technology and
being a critical mind is going to allow
you
to uh succeed and Thrive rather than
becoming obsolete and you have to
realize that life is a marathon is not a
Sprint you have to study hard college
degree graduate degrees relearn all your
time retrain yourself try to be flexible
learn to be
curious and also in your investment
decisions if you do day trading if you
gamble with crypto Mimi stocks spars
you're going to lose your
shirt you have to invest and save every
day doesn't matter that you don't have
enough income you should save every year
15% of your income because your Social
Security is not going to be there when
you retired there'll be too many old
people not enough young so you have to
have a additional lag of private savings
you to have Diversified portfolio us
Global equities variety of assets
Commodities domestic foreign and you're
not going to make 100% per year nobody
does you make 8 to
10% but the principle of compound
interest 8% per year compounds a lot of
money over the long term and if you work
hard study hard retain yourself become
intellectually curious you say
you invest in a investment way not a
speculative way over time you're going
to do well so think of life as being a
marathon rather than a Sprint and if you
do that probably you're going to survive
and thrive in spite of the mega threats
especially if you're engaged with
Society with your political system to
make this a better world for yourself
for your friends for your family for
your children for your fellow humans
[Music]
thank you very much for having me today
was a great pleasure
[Music]